I now turn to the prime minister's
second priority which is to reduce debt
here too our plan is on track underlying
debt is forecast to be 92.4 percent of
GDP next year then 97.3
94.6
94.8 percent before falling to 94.6 in
2728 we are meeting the debt priority
and with a buffer of six and a half
billion pounds it means we are meeting
our fiscal rule to have debt falling as
a percentage of GDP by the fifth year of
the forecast
as a proportion of GDP
our debt remains lower than the USA
Canada France Italy and Japan and
because of the decisions I take today
and the improved outlook for public
finances underlying debt in five years
time is now forecast to be nearly three
percentage points of GDP lower than it
was in the Autumn that means more money
for our public services and a lower
burden for future Generations deeply
held conservative values which we put
into practice today
at the Autumn statement I also announced
that public sector net borrowing must be
below three percent of GDP over the same
period the obr confirmed today that
we're meeting that rule with a buffer of
39.2 billion in fact our deficit Falls
in every single year of the forecast
with borrowing falling from 5.1 percent
of GDP and 2324 to 3.2 percent to 2.8
percent to 2.2 percent and 1.7 in 27.28
even better in the final two years of
the forecast our current budget is in
Surplus meaning we only borrow for
investment and not for day-to-day
spending
day-to-day departmental spending will
grow at one percent a year on average in
real terms after 24 25 until the end of
the forecast period Capital plans are
maintained at the same level set at the
Autumn statements